The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In this lecture I'd like
to discuss with
you structural elements.
Structural elements are, of
course, employed to model
beam, plate and shell structures
and are most
important elements.
Because of their importance in
engineering practice much
research and development effort
has been focused on the
development of efficient
structural elements.
In this and the next lecture I'd
like to discuss with you
some modern effective
elements.
We will first discuss shell
elements and then beam
elements and then we go back to
use the shell elements, a
concept that we discussed in
some actual applications.
When we do structural analysis
we should keep one method in
mind, namely that in a
geometrically nonlinear
analysis, a flat shell, referred
to as a plate, goes
very rapidly over into the
behavior of a shell because of
the curvature that develops
as the plate deforms.
Therefore, to analyze
geometrically nonlinear plates
we really are quite well off
using general shell elements.
And I'd like to now focus our
attention on the development
of general shell elements that
we actually then employ to
analyze plates as well
as general shells.
There are various solution
approaches that one can follow
for the development of
efficient elements.
And one such approach is
the use of general
beam and shell theories.
I'm thinking of beams as well
as shells although I want to
focus our attention on shells,
really, in this first lecture.
One starts with beam or shell
theory as general as possible
and develops the governing
differential equations.
From the governing differential
equation one
develops variational
formulations and one
discretizes those variation
formulations using finite
element interpolations.
This is the approach
that is taken.
The disadvantage of that
approach is, in general, lack
of generality of the approach.
You're starting off with
a particular shell
theory, beam theory.
You of course would like to
have that shell theory as
general as possible but you
will find that really, the
shell theory that you're
starting of will mostly only
be applicable to a certain
class of shells.
Therefore your finite elements
that you're developing would
also be only applicable to that
same class of shells.
And that means in engineering
practice, in actual usage, the
user has to be very familiar
for which the particular
element developed,
as shown here.
I'll discuss now for what
kinds of shells this
particular shell element
is really applicable.
We would rather like to have
shell elements that are
applicable to any shell.
Of course this is a
very big aim, very
difficult to achieve.
But this is what we would
like to have ideally
in engineering practice.
The other difficulty with this
approach is that frequently a
large number of nodal degrees of
freedom have to be carried
along in the development
of the shell elements.
And what I'm thinking of there
is that you don't just have
translations and rotations at
the nodal points, which has
engineering degrees of freedom
that we would like to have and
see in for the element, but
you also have to have
additional degrees of freedoms
relating to the curvatures in
the elements.
And so on.
So this of course would mean, or
does mean, difficult use of
such elements and these reasons,
these two reasons
here have really driven the
research and development
efforts in different
directions.
Another approach is to
use simple elements.
Simple elements, but a large
number of elements, then to
model very complex beam
and shell structures.
As an example I'd like to just
refer you to a 3-node
triangle, a flat element in
which the plate-bending
behavior is modeled in a
particular way and the plane
stress behavior is modeled as
a constant strain, constant
stress element.
These two are superimposed,
these two behaviors are
superimposed and you have a very
simple shell element that
in certain analyses can
be quite effective.
Of course we have to recognize
in this approach that the
coupling between the membrane
and bending action is only
introduced at the
element nodes.
That is a major disadvantage.
And that is the reason why you
need so many elements to model
a shell and that if we use a
triangular 3-noded element
with just a constant strain,
constant stress element to
model the membrane behavior, the
membrane action, of course
the membrane action is quite
poorly approximated.
And that is another reason why
we need so many elements to
model a complex shell
behavior.
Here on this viewgraph I'm
showing a picture of the
element that I just
referred to.
Here you have a triangular
element in the three
dimensional space.
Notice we introduce a local
coordinate system, x bar 2, x
bar 3, x bar 1.
Local coordinate system, and
in this local coordinate
system we measure the
displacements and rotations.
And we superimpose for this
element the bending behavior,
the bending behavior
corresponding to this degree
of freedom, that degree of
freedom and this degree of
freedom at every node,
of course.
We add, or superimpose onto
this bending behavior the
membrane behavior which
corresponds to these two
degrees of freedom.
And we immediately notice that
corresponding to this degree
of freedom we don't have a real
physical stiffness and we
introduce a little artificial
stiffness as shown down here.
Now this artificial stiffness
has to be selected and you
want to select it such as to
take out the singularity out
of the system but yet make the
stiffness not too big so as to
destroy the behavior
of the element.
Because it's an artificial
stiffness you really want to
make it as small as possible
just to take out the
singularity out of this element
when you apply this
element in the modeling of
general shell structures.
This artificial stiffness
actually is quite bothersome
in nonlinear analysis.
It can provide problems and
we really don't like it.
But if we use this approach we
have to introduce it and well,
we have to, so to say, live with
it, with the difficulties
that we encounter.
But the other approach that
I want to discuss with you
really quite extensively in
these two lectures, namely
using the isoparametric
elements, having curved
elements there as well, we
don't introduce this
artificial stiffness anymore
because our experiences of
introducing it in nonlinear
analysis show us that there
are many difficulties that
come into the analysis
procedure if you have this
artificial stiffness.
So we got rid of it.
We don't need to use it any
longer for the more modern
elements that I will be talking
about just now.
The approach for these modern
elements is to use
isoparametric interpolations
and we talk then about the
isoparametric (degenerate)
beams and shell elements.
"Degenerate" because we
degenerate these elements, or
we obtain these elements I
should say, by degeneration
from three dimensional
behavior.
We will talk much more
about it just now.
But in essence we are saying
we take the 3-D continuum
equations and we degenerate
those equations to the
particular shell behavior and
beam behavior for beams that
we would like to capture.
The resulting elements can be
used to model quite general
beam and shell structures.
And that is, of course, a very
large advantage in engineering
practice if you can use the
same elements to model a
variety of structures.
The basic approach of this
isoparametric interpolation is
to use the total and updated
Lagrangian formulations that
we developed earlier.
We talked in the earlier
lectures quite extensively
about the total updated
Lagrangian formulation, the
continuum mechanics equations,
as well as the finite element
discretization of the continuum
mechanics equations.
But we applied the final
discretization only to 2-D and
3-D solid elements.
Now we want to do the same
for shell elements.
We recall that in the T.L.
formulation the governing
equation is this one here, which
is nothing else than the
principal of virtual work
operating on the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress and
the variation on the
Green-Lagrange strain.
This integral has taken over
the original volume of the
structure, of the
element, when we
develop a finite element.
And this of course, the internal
virtual work, and
here we have the external
virtual work.
Notice the linearization of
this left integral here
resulted into these
three integrals.
We went through that
linearization in quite some
detail and we talked about
the individual terms.
I don't think it's now necessity
to review that
material anymore.
Please refer to the
earlier lectures.
The same approach of course
we used also for the U.L.
formulation.
Here is the general starting
point, the principle of
virtual work now, using second
Piola-Kirchhoff stresses refer
to the configuration
at time t.
Variations in the Green-Lagrange
strains refer
to the time configuration
at time t.
This gives the internal virtual
work corresponding to
time t plus delta t,
t plus delta t.
And this is the external virtual
work, same external
virtual work of course that
we are having in the total
Lagrangian formulation.
The linearization of the left
hand side integral here
results into these
three integrals.
Once again we talked about
the linearization quiet
extensively and if you refer to
the earlier lectures surely
you recognize individual terms
that you're seeing here now.
We use these governing equations
for the total
Lagrangian and updated
Lagrangian formulation to
develop the general
shell elements.
And what we have to do now is
to impose on these equations
the basic assumptions of
beam and shell action.
And let us go now through these
basic assumptions one by
one carefully.
The first assumption is that
the material particles
originally on a straight line
normal to the mid-surface of
the beam or the shell remain
on that straight line
throughout the response
history.
This is one most important
assumption.
You must have encountered this
assumption or at least some
form of it already earlier in
your discussion of beam
theories and possibly
shell theories.
Let's look at this assumption
more closely, so.
For beams we would say plane
sections initially normal to
the mid-surface remain
plane sections during
the response history.
This is basically saying
the same thing
what I just said earlier.
And if you look at this closely
you recognize that we
do not say that the plane
sections initially normal to
the mid-surface remain plane
sections during the response
history and remain normal
to the mid-surface.
We don't say that.
That's of course being
said when you use the
Euler-Bernoulli beam theory.
We don't say this, that the
plane sections remain normal
to the mid-surface throughout
the response history.
We don't say that and because we
don't say that we in effect
include in an approximate
way shear deformations.
In other words, we look here
at the effect of transverse
shear deformations is included,
and hence the lines
initially normal to the
mid-surface do not remain
normal to the mid-surface
during the deformations.
Let's look at what this
means pictorially.
Here we have a section of a beam
at time 0 and we draw a
line normal, that is, at 90
degrees to the mid-surface,
shown as a dashed line.
And we identify particles
on that line.
Here we have four
such [? rad ?]
material particles.
Now the beam will move, deform,
go through large
displacements, large
rotations.
But actually we assume
small strains.
And we see that these material
particles which were
originally up here are
now down here.
We identify that these material
particles are still
on a straight line.
But this straight line is not
anymore normal, that it is at
90 degrees to the mid-surface.
And because it is not any more
normal to the mid-surface we
do include shear deformations
approximately because we
assume that the shear
deformations are constant
throughout the thickness
of the beam.
This is a most important
assumption.
We're looking here what looks
like a beam but actually, if
you think of another dimension
here, you can directly see
that the same picture is
also applicable to
the motion of a shell.
The second important assumption
is that the stress
in the direction normal to the
beam or shell mid-surface is
zero throughout the
response history.
In other words, there is no
stress developed normal to the
mid-surface.
But notice that here is a stress
along the material
fiber that is initially normal
to the mid-surface is
considered.
Now this material fiber which
is initially normal to the
mid-surface will not remain
normal to the
mid-surface as I just said.
And in the motion we will
consider always this stress in
the direction of that material
fiber which was originally
normal to the mid-surface.
So after motion has taken
place we are not really
talking anymore exactly--
you want to look in great detail
at what's happening--
we don't talk anymore exactly
about the stress, that is
normal to the current
mid-surface.
But we always talk about the
stress in the direction of the
fiber that was initially normal
to the mid-surface.
That's being said here.
And the third assumption, also
most important assumption, is
that the thickness of the beam
or shell remains constant.
Here then we clearly identify
that we are using really a
small-- we are assuming small
strain conditions, but we
allow for very large
displacements and rotations.
Well, with these three
kinematic and static
assumptions clearly identified
we are now ready to actually
develop the shell element
interpolations.
And let's go at that.
The first point is that we
incorporate the geometric
assumptions.
Straight lines normal to the
mid-surface remain straight,
put here in quotes, that
geometric assumption and the
geometric assumption that the
shell thickness remains
constant throughout
the whole motion.
These were two assumptions
that we just discussed.
We incorporate that into our
shell element formulation by
using the appropriate geometric
and displacement
interpolations.
We incorporate the condition of
zero stress normal to the
mid-surface, I put it in quotes
here, because remember,
we are talking about the stress
in the direction of the
fiber that was originally normal
to the mid-surface.
We incorporate this condition
by using the appropriate
stress-strain law.
Let's talk first about this
assumption and then about this
assumption, how we're using
these to actually develop our
shell elements.
To focus our attention
I'd like to talk
about a 9-node element.
However.
we will later on see that in
practice actually we don't use
the 9-node element very much.
We actually recommend the use
of a 16-node element and a
4-node element but this
9-node element in some
analysis is also used.
And it certainly is an element
with which I can discuss with
you, share with you all the
experiences regarding the
formulation of the elements
because what we're talking
about now really is applicable
to any of the elements.
In fact, we're talking about
variable number nodes
elements, where the number of
nodes can be selected by the
analyst and the geometric
assumptions that we're now
talking about are the same for
any one of these elements.
How do we go about
the formulation?
Well, one important point is
that we introduce at each node
lying on the mid-surface, and
here we see such 9-nodes, a
director vector, a director
vector t v n k, t referring
already to the geometry
at time t.
Of course this director vector
is actually input by the
analyst for time 0 and then
it evolves with the
motion of the shell.
Also we're introducing for the
analysis, and that's being
done automatically in the
computer program, these two
vectors here, t v 1 k and t v
2 k, which are normal to the
director vector.
These vectors are calculated
automatically in
the computer program.
We talk more about it
a little later.
Notice that the thickness here
at this node is a k, and
notice that v n k at node
k-- k of course
stands for that node--
acts into the direction off
the thickness here.
Notice that such [? triad ?]
of vectors is of course
being worked with at
each of these nodes.
And notice that the thickness
at the nodes can change.
The element is defined
as follows.
As far as the analyst is
concerned the initial nodal
point coordinates of all
the nodal points on the
mid-surface must be input.
Also the initial director vector
must be input, here now
you see the zero, and the
thickness at every
node must be input.
Notice if these director vectors
at all of the nodes
are known, with the thicknesses
at the nodes of
course, then we can interpolate
the thickness at
any point of the mid-surface
of the shell and we can
interpolate the director vector
corresponding to any
point on the mid-surface.
Here such point on the
mid-surface we get the
thickness at that point, from
the thicknesses that we have
here, and from the
director vectors.
And of course we are also
getting the director vector at
this point from these
director vectors.
So the analyst must put in the
nodal point coordinates of the
mid-surface nodes and the
direction cosines of these
director vectors.
Much of it of course
can be generated
in a practical analysis.
We use an isoparametric
coordinate system with
coordinates r, s, and t.
The coordinates r and s
correspond to a measure in the
mid-surface.
The coordinate t is measured
in the direction of the
director vectors.
The geometry at time 0 is
interpolated as shown here in
this equation.
0 x i gives us the coordinates,
three, i goes
from one to three, of any
material particle in the
stationary coordinate frame.
I should point out once more
very strongly that we use a
stationary Cartesian coordinate
frame, x1, x2, x3,
to describe the geometry of the
element and to work with
our element.
This coordinate frame, x1,
x2, x3, is stationary.
In that stationary coordinate
frame of course we are
measuring the coordinates
of any material particle
corresponding to time
0, corresponding
to time t, et cetera.
The same way as we discussed it
in earlier lectures when we
talked about the analysis of
solids, 2-D and 3-D solids,
and when we talked about the
continuum mechanics equations.
So here these coordinates of the
material particles, as the
material particles are moving
through the stationary
coordinate frame, are given
by the right hand side.
And what do we see here?
k is 1 to n, n is the number of
nodes for the element that
I've shown you and
would be nine.
h k are the interpolation
functions corresponding to the
two-dimensional surface
of the element.
In other words, these h
k's are really the 2-D
interpolation functions as we
are used to see them for plane
stress, plane strain, and
axisymmetric analysis.
Same interpolation functions.
These are the nodal point
coordinates at time 0.
Here we have t, that is the
third isoparametric
coordinate.
We talked about it just now.
k, going from 1 to n again.
a k are the thicknesses
at the nodal points.
h k here is exactly the same
h k that you see here.
And these are the direction
cosines of
the director vectors.
Director vector n means director
vector k, or normal.
n really stands for normal, but
it's really the director
vector referring to the
director vector k,
of course, a node.
0 means time 0 and i means
the components, the three
components of the
director vector.
That's what we're
looking at here.
Now if you leave this term out
then you would have simply the
interpolation of the mid-surface
as for a membrane
element, of course curved
mid-surface.
This term here is added in to
take into account the effect
of the shell thickness.
Similarly at time t we have,
applying the same
interpolation t,
x, i here now.
Here we have t, x, i, k, same
h k that we talked about
earlier, same summing that
we talked about just now.
Here now t, v, n, i, k, the
direction cosines, also
director vectors.
Director vector k
at time t now.
Notice that all we have done in
this term and in that term
is to substitute for the 0 that
we had here and that we
had there, the t now.
Of course this t means
time t, this t here
means coordinate t.
That's why we put a circle
around it and wrote it out
there once more.
This is the coordinate, the
isoparametric coordinate t.
r s coordinates go in here, t
coordinate goes in there.
What has happened here is that
originally our director vector
might look like shown in
this picture here.
The node coordinates are given
here, 0 x i k, and in the time
from time 0 to time t this
director vector moves to look
as shown now here.
And of course the nodal point
itself has moved as well.
So it's these quantities here,
these [? rad ?] quantities
that we're using here, which
carries a curve.
Well, to obtain the displacement
of any material
particle within the shell we
proceed now exactly the same
way as we have proceeded
in the development
of 3-D solid elements.
We take the interpolation for
the geometry at time t,
subtract the interpolation for
the geometry at time 0 and we
get the displacements
corresponding to time t.
The result is this
equation here.
Here we have the displacements
of any material
particle in the shell.
Here we have the nodal point
displacements from
time 0 to time t.
Here we have the director
vectors at time t, so to say,
minus the director vectors
at time 0.
Really these are the direction
cosines corresponding to the
director vector at time t, minus
the direction cosines of
the director vector
corresponding at time 0.
Of course this quantity here is
obtained by this equation
and that quantity here is simply
obtained by subtracting
the right hand sides
corresponding to t x i and 0 x
i the way you just have seen
them on the previous
viewgraphs.
The incremental displacement
from time t to time t plus
delta t is similarly obtained
from this relationship here.
And the result is shown here
where now we have here the
increments in the nodal
point displacements.
And here we have the increments
in the direction
cosines of the director vectors
from time t to time t
plus delta t.
The equation is given
right there.
Well, with the equations that
we have developed so far we
are almost ready to establish
the strain displacement
matrices for the T.L. and U.L.
formulations of the element.
We have the coordinate
interpolations for the
material particles.
We discussed those.
And we have at the moment also
the interpolation of the
incremental displacements of the
material particles in the
shell element in terms of
nodal point incremental
displacements and the increments
of the direction
cosines of the director vectors
at the nodal points.
What we, however, want is
to have the incremental
displacements in terms of the
nodal point displacements and
nodal point rotations.
The nodal point rotations
because the incremental nodal
point displacements and nodal
point rotations are the
engineering type quantities that
we can nicely deal with
in a computer program when we
analyze shell structures.
So what we want is to express v
n i k, the increments in the
direction cosines of the
director vectors, from time t
to time t plus delta
t in terms of
the nodal point rotations.
And that is achieved
as follows.
Here we have the stationary
coordinate frame x1, x2, x3.
e 1 is a vector into the x1
direction, e 2 the vector into
the x2 direction, e 3 the vector
into the x3 direction.
Here we show v n k for
nodal point k.
In other words, a director
vector, at time 0.
This one is input
by the analyst.
These two are calculated
in the program.
And of course there are such two
for every nodal point k.
For every nodal point k we also
put in a director vector.
Now the convention that is used,
that can be used for the
v 1 and v 2 calculations, that
convention is given down here.
Notice that if v n points into
the e 3 direction then v 1
points into the 1 direction
and v 2
points into the 2 direction.
By that I mean into the e 1 and
into the e 2 directions.
Notice, this is a detail, that
when v n points into the e 2
direction this formula breaks
down and you need to use some
other convention.
But that is a detail.
We don't really need
to discuss that
very much here now.
Anyways, let us say then at
every nodal point k, v n has
been input by the user, v
1, v 2, calculated by
the computer program.
We notice that these
two are once again
perpendicular to v n.
Then we can directly say that
the increment in the direction
cosines of the vector, the
director vector, is given via
this relationship here.
Now I've written this down
already for time t.
Of course it also holds for
time 0, all you do is
substitute for t, 0.
It holds in fact for any time
of the motion that we are
considering.
Let's see why this holds.
Well, this picture here shows
what's happening.
Here we have v n, here we have
v 2, here we have v 1.
Notice alpha is the rotation
about v 1, beta is the
rotation about v 2.
Notice that with the rotation
beta about v 2 here, we of
course have an increment in
this vector shown by this
component because this here is
now v n at time t plus delta t
when alpha k is 0.
When alpha k is 0.
Now of course you would also
have the alpha k component
coming in and that means you
have to add also this term.
Notice that once you have
obtained this vector you want
to normalize its
lengths again.
But this picture here shows
why this term is a correct
term to use in this formula
and you can extend this
picture to also include
this term.
With this relationship we can
substitute for v n and that's
now done in this equation.
We have substituted for v n and
have now our increments in
the displacements for the
material particle within the
shell in terms of nodal point
incremental displacements and
rotations about these v 1 and
v 2 axes that we defined.
Well, having established this
interpolation for the
incremental displacements and,
of course, the interpolations
for the geometries of the
element at time 0, at time t,
we can directly establish the
strain displacement matrices.
And we will see we can then
set up the k matrix, the f
vector, the elements that go
into the equilibrium equations
the way that we discussed it
in the earlier lectures.
And from the solution of k u
equals r or k delta u equals
delta r in nonlinear analysis,
we of course get our nodal
point rotations, alpha
k and beta k.
And once we have calculated
these nodal point rotations we
obtain by this relationship
here the v n at time
t plus delta t.
In other words, what we're
doing really here is we
integrate over all of the angle,
alpha k and beta k, to
get a more accurate
approximation for the nodal
point vector, of the director
vector, I should say, at time
t plus delta t.
Notice that if you do this
integration in one step with
the Euler forward method, you
get back the equation that we
had earlier on the viewgraph.
And which I tried to explain or
discuss with you using this
picture that you saw.
And I mentioned also that after
this integration of
course we want to normalize the
lengths of this vector to
make it always a unit
length vector.
We recognize that with this
approach we have only five
degrees of freedom per node.
Three translations in the
Cartesian coordinate
directions which are stationary,
and two rotations
refer to the local nodal point
vectors v 1 and v 2 at time t.
Now notice in geometric
nonlinear analysis, of course,
this vector and that vector,
t v 1 and t v 2, change
direction so our alpha k and
beta k are rotations that are
measured about changing
directions.
That is an important
point to recognize.
Let's look at one pictorial
representation of what's happening.
Here we have node k.
We have a smooth shell, say,
that is discretized using four
shell elements.
I've taken one shell element
away as shown here so that we
can look into the shell.
And at that node we have, as
shown now, v 1 and v 2 at time
t and the director vector
corresponding to a time t.
We measure at that time
alpha k and beta k
about v 1 and v 2.
And we also measure the
displacements of the node, u
1, u 2, u 3.
So notice that this node
moves as shown.
These are the three
translational degrees of
freedom and this director vector
here moves to a new
position and also changes
direction.
And that new director
vector of course is
given here in red.
Notice that there is no
physical stiffness
corresponding to the rotation
about the director vector.
No physical stiffness.
The five degrees of freedom
that the element very
naturally carries, u 1, u
2, u 3, alpha k, beta k.
Alpha, beta at every node k.
If only shell elements connect
to node k and the node k is
not subjected to
boundary-prescribed rotations
then we only need to assign
these five degrees of freedom
to the node and only work with
at that node.
However if we deal with a node
to which also beam element is
connected, which of course in
general has three rotational
degrees of freedom, or a node
on which a boundary rotation
other than alpha k or beta k is
imposed then we transform
the two nodal rotations, alpha
k and beta k, to the three
Cartesian axes.
Because this way we can directly
deal then with the
connection here and
the imposition of
the boundary rotation.
We can do so directly using
these three rotations now
measured in the Cartesian
axis directions.
I mentioned already that the
above interpolations for 0 x
i, t x i and u i, in other
words, for the original
geometry, the current geometry,
and the incremental
displacements the way we have
developed them, they can
directly be used to obtain
the strain displacement
transformation matrices.
And we really do so in the same
way as for the 3-D solid
elements which we discussed
in an earlier lecture.
However, there's one method to
recognize, and I briefly
pointed it out also already in
the earlier lecture, that
using this expression here--
and I now must refer to the
earlier material that we
discussed--
using this expression to obtain
the strain displacement
matrix, we realize that we
obtain the exact linear strain
displacement matrix.
However, using this expression
here to develop the nonlinear
strain displacement matrix, t 0
b n l, for the shell element
only in approximation to the
exact second-order strain
displacement rotation expression
is obtained because
the internal element
displacements depend
nonlinearly on the nodal
point rotations.
I pointed that out earlier.
Please refer back to that
discussion to obtain a deeper
understanding of what
I mean here.
The important point, of course,
is that we do obtain
the exact linear strain
displacement matrix, so at
convergence in an iteration, k
delta u equals delta r, when
we have converged we actually
have the exact solution to the
model that we're using,
of course.
So this is important that we
obtain the appropriate and
exact t 0 b l matrix.
The effect of what we are
neglecting here was earlier
mentioned and please refer
back to that lecture.
We finally need to still impose
the condition that the
stress in the direction
normal to the shell
mid-surface is zero.
Remember this was one further
assumption that we discussed
at the beginning of
this lecture.
We use a direction
of the director
vector as a normal direction.
This means that at each Gauss
integration point within the
element, and which we want to
evaluate the stress-strain
law, we first of all set up a
system of vectors, e bar r, e
bar s, e t, that are mutually
perpendicular.
Now let's look here into the
picture above and we see here
at a particular Gauss point,
schematically shown, the
vector e r and e s which are
vectors corresponding to the r
and s axes.
e t is a vector corresponding
to the direction of the
director vector at that point.
e t we accept as the normal
direction, that's for the
shell at that point, and we
construct e bar s and e bar r
to be vectors perpendicular
to e t and to themselves.
And that is achieved by this
relationship here.
Having now established e t, e
bar r and e bar s, we use this
stress-strain law.
And by this I mean let's
look first what's
in these round brackets.
We use this stress-strain law
corresponding to these
directions.
In other words, the directions e
bar r, e bar s and e t where
this is the normal direction,
this corresponds to the normal
direction e t.
Notice by putting zeroes here
we impose the fact that into
the direction e t we
have zero stress.
Of course this matrix
is symmetric.
Notice we have k here which is
a shear correction factor
applied to the transfer shear
stresses in the shell.
New of course is Poisson's
ratio and
e is Young's modulus.
Now this is the material law
corresponding to e t, e
bar r, e bar s.
And what we now have to do is
transform this material law at
every integration point to
the global directions.
Global directions because for
the global x1, x2, x3
directions we have established
the b, the strain
displacement matrices.
And that gives us this material,
or c, shell.
This q s h t, q s h is, I
think, quite well known.
Let me show you the form
of it briefly.
It's a transformation matrix
where we show some of the
terms here, as you can see.
And these terms, l 1, m
1, n 1, et cetera, are
defined down here.
And l 1, for example, is nothing
else but the cosine of
the angle between
e 1 and e bar r.
In other words, it's a
transformation matrix that you
are probably quite familiar
with in linear analysis.
It's the matrix that transforms
the stress and
strain components from one
coordinate system to the other
coordinate system.
And of course the coordinate
systems that we are
transforming, that we're using
here, are the bar, e bar, r, e
bar s, e t coordinate system on
the one side and e 1, e 2,
e 3 on the other side.
Well, using this matrix we
assure that the columns and
rows 1 to 3 in c s h reflect
that the stress normal to the
shell mid-surface is zero.
This holds true because,
remember if we go back once
more to the viewgraph, we
have set this column and
corresponding row to
zero elements.
And of course this means that
the stress normal to the shell
surface is zero.
I should also briefly point
out that we have a plane
stress condition corresponding
to the other direction of
stresses, in other words,
the e bar r and e
bar s direction stresses.
We have a plane stress condition
as you can see here.
And of course this term would
go with it as well.
This term and these terms here
reflect the plane stress
situation in the plane
of the shell, zero
stress through the thickness.
And all that we are transforming
to the global
system now here--
that fact, that physical
fact--
of course must still be
reflected in c s h.
And that's what's being said
here at that point.
If you want to do plastic
analysis, creep analysis, you
proceed in the same way.
But you calculate then once
again the stress-strain
metrics as in the analysis
of 3-D solids.
And having got that
stress-strain matrix, six by
six matrix, you impose the
condition that the stress
normal to the mid-surface is
zero in much the same way as
what we have done here for the
elastic material condition.
Finally, regarding the kinematic
descriptions that we
talked about for the shell
elements, it is interesting to
note that also transition
elements can be developed.
These can be quite useful in
practical analysis because
they are elements with some
mid-surface nodes that carry,
in other words, associate
director vectors and five
degrees of freedom per node
and some top and bottom
surface nodes with three
translational degrees of
freedom per node.
These elements would be used,
for example, to model
shell-to-solid transitions or to
model shell intersections.
And here you see one such
typical element just
schematically shown.
Here we have a mid-surface
node, three translational
degrees of freedom corresponding
to the
stationary coordinate frame,
two rotational degrees of
freedom the way we talked about
it just now, mid-surface
node here and top and bottom
nodes here with three
translational degrees
of freedom for
each of these nodes.
Notice we can directly couple
3-D solids to this phase here
and shell elements to
this phase here.
We haven't shown mid-surface
nodes here, but you would,
say, have all the mid-surface
nodes here and then surely
shell element can directly be
coupled into here in such
situation as schematically shown
right down here on this
viewgraph where we have solid
elements on this side and
transition element right
there and shell
elements on that side.
Because here you would continue
with shell elements,
you would continue with
solid elements here.
And once again three
translational degrees of
freedom for these top and bottom
surface nodes and five
degrees of freedom at shell
mid-surface nodes as shown for
that node right here.
Notice we can also use these
transition elements to model
shell intersections very nicely
as exemplified up here.
Well, this brings me to the
end of what I wanted to
discuss with you in
this lecture.
Of course what we have not done
yet is to look at example
solutions and what I'd like to
do in the next lecture is
first of all talk with you
about beam elements, the
isoparametric beam element,
which is formulated much in
the same way as the
shell elements
that we just discussed.
And then I'd like to show you
applications of the beam
elements as well as the
shell elements.
So please, if you are interested
in this subject
matter, continue looking at the
second tape, part two of
this set of lectures.
Thank you very much for
your attention.